hello everyone and welcome to round five
over the twenty twenty feet a candidates
tournament it's basically the Battle of
wildcards kiddo Alex and Co versus
Maxima sherrilyn Grove and it's quite
the game it's it's like they're trying
to create an even more complicated game
than that of adding versus Caruana but
we'll see it's maxime is the neither of
so you know there's gonna be did
anything can happen on the board but
before we check out the actual game I
would like to invite you to check out a
very very short video a three-minute
video from a subscriber from saw Tony
from Africa he sent it to me it
basically was supposed to be a part of
the subscribers video but he was late
for it but still I do want you to see it
he gathered a lot of a lot of children
and he's teaching them chess and it's
very I really enjoyed this video so if
you have three minutes to spare do check
out that video it will be the first
thing you see in the description below
just click on the link and only then
come back to watch this video so if you
can spare the three minutes so for those
of you who were able to do that
congratulations on being excellent
subscribers and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the game here we go
and also I don't know I thought that I
asked if he will need any help with the
equipment or maybe some chess board some
chess clocks that that he should tell me
and then I'm hoping we could create some
sort of a fundraiser or something which
is something I'm I've been thinking
about for a while to do for for a lot of
clubs and well yeah especially for
children who need it but so far I
haven't had the opportunity to to act on
that but maybe this can be our first
accomplishment but we'll see how it goes
so a little bit let's return to the game
a kid Alex Inka versus Maxie Marshall a
gruff and we do have some nice photos to
check from this event there we have it
the handshake before the game where
Maxime is hoping to get some eye contact
action but key releasing no way a
handshake is all you're getting and here
we have a nice nice photo of Maxime you
can see that off the board he's he's a
very happy fellow but during the game
he's he's quite serious about what's
going on and also a nice close-up of
Alec Cinco and I just enjoyed that as
you
see also a wild nipple appears in the
background checking up what's going on
on the board and there's a lot going on
on the board so let's check it out Alex
& Co opens with E 4 and something that
we're all looking forward to whenever
someone plays e4 against Maxime he goes
for his night off so c5 the Sicilian
defense is on the board we have Knight
to f3 b6 and now d4 we have C character
snipe characters Knight to f6 for a
nightcap for some b4 Knight f6 Knight to
c3 and a6 so then I drove is on the
board and here you can play pretty much
any move Bishop e3 Bishop e2 Bishop c4 h
3g 3 f3 so all of these are possible
moves but here we have f3 there by Alex
angle we have e 6 by Maxine Bishop to e3
and now b5 preparing to fena khair to
the LightSquared Bishop Queen to d2 now
you don't have to worry so much about b4
as your efore point is nicely protected
by by the f3 pawn so if this you can
simply go Knight it for maybe solidify
would be three you're gonna get your
Bishop to c4 and so on it's playable and
not much here to look for for black so
Nightbeat the d7 Maxine continues
development with a three and now h5 and
here a queenside castle by Alex angle
with the shop the b7 and now there is
one game in the database where h3 was
played but here Maxine goes sorry Alex
and could go skiing to be won and it is
already as a move 11 that we have a
completely new game so you can you can
know that he came prepared and he does
have something in store for Maxime
Schneider with Bishop to e7 and now rook
to g1 saying that ok I'm ready to start
pushing my pawns here we have roped the
c8 basically a signature knight or move
or you always want this rook on the C
file and in most lines you will
sacrifice it for a for the knight on c3
but ok for the moment the wild ef3 pawn
is guarding e4 maybe not just right away
we have Bishop to e2 now for the
preparing g4 and the night to b6 now
from here the knight can come to c4 if
needed so Queen back the e1 you don't
want Knight to c4 to come with an attack
on the Queen and the
the shop to have to give up your light
square bishop so Quinta II won and now
comes night after d7 preparing to bring
the other night at the c5 but also e5 if
needed
and here comes g4 with h ty press ng for
rook captures n g4 and here in g6 by
Maxine and here Alex and co really
started the thing because well there's
there's a lot of possibilities here as
you can see there are some targets here
in blacks position so even feel free to
pause the video here and try to figure
out how you would continue the game for
white in this position while I'll give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who sacrificed anything
congratulations on being an excellent
player against the night off and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show Alex & Co play the rook captures
and g6 here but night cactus is also
very interesting so we're just gonna
check out what happens here so it seems
like the Queen is trapped so of course
the knight has to be captured F captures
on e6 rook captures on g6 and now the
Kings position is pretty much busted but
Knights the f8 attacks the rook and
covers the e6 pawn so rook the g7 and
now Knight B to d7 and going old turtle
mode now that you have to defend Queen
to g3 and now comes a bishop to f6
attacking the rook but now Bishop to g5
impossible to capture the room because
you lose the Queen so here you would
have a bishop trade captures captures
and now black has this a very very nice
defensive resource rook to h3 saying
that okay if captures then captures and
then I'm just up too much material and
you've pretty much lost all of your
attackers so you would see something
like queen g4 or queen east 7 guarding
the pawn here and it's a really crazy
position if rook captures and d6
to kick away the defender of well the
attacker of the rook and g5 then you can
even capture on h2 and then sort of
decide where to go from there really
crazy
anything can happen but you know it was
possible however Alex & Co decided not
to go for Knight captures and he sits
but rather for rook captures on g6
and it does pack a lot
poison for example if you capture here
then night chapters on e6 traps the
Queen but only only kind of because here
you have Bishop the aged for making room
for the Queen while also attacking the
White Queen so here we would again go
into a capture fest night capture Sun b8
Bishop character Sun d1 you would have
night characters on b7 Bishop captures
and c3 characters on d6 would check King
d8 captures the actress captures and now
of course captures on h2 and well the
bishop is under attack you move
dealership and you go into this end game
where where it's two night two nights in
the rook against a rock and two bishops
but wife is up two points so white white
would definitely be better here so as
it's an open game to bishops against two
knights the games on both sides of the
board post material advantage definitely
definitely better for white so of course
Maxime doesn't capture the rook instead
maxine goes for a counter blow rook
captures and c3 and now again we have to
calculate here Alexander was burning a
lot of time and Maxime pretty much
played all of this instantly as he is a
matter of specialty specialist so even
even crazy positions like these in the
night or if don't really I don't really
throw him off guard so what's happening
here if you captured the rook then you
get Knight to a4 you push back the Queen
and after Queen b3 now you can capture
on g6 and now after Knight captures and
e6 Queen to c8 and here we basically get
a draw by repetition ig6 check now you
cannot go here and allow something like
Queen to d7 could be very uncomfortable
so you go here and then we most likely
would see a nice draw by repetition here
so instead of this after rook captures
in c3 Alex and who just continues a
happily attacking Knight captures on e6
now asking Maxime what do you do now
so again if you capture here now it's a
bit different if you capture here then
Queen captures on c3
comes with an attack on the rook on h8
and so after a 5 defending it now Queen
b3 and it's not now it's a bit of an
uncomfortable position with the Queen
having access here you can double up on
the G file you have pressure on d6 it's
a
really crazy position where we're only
white can be better so of course after
night captures on e6 Maxime just moves
the Queen Queen to c8 and now puts
pressure on c2 so just it's just amazing
how Maxime always does this he always
takes this exchange sacrifice on c3 and
he always somehow somehow breaks through
and on the Queen side so Knight the g7
width check first
and now King to f8 King the d8 is also
very interesting however then if King
today then this runs into a force
variation Bishop characters and b6
Knight captures and now rook captures
and b6 bishop characters and these six
rook captures and v6 with check and now
after King to c7 you have Knight to f5
defending the rook while still
threatening to capture the rope here and
here black would be in a very tough spot
for example if here you can just capture
a Bishop captures with check and the now
Queen g3 check keeps the King in the
center of the board you cannot go here
because Knight check picks up the Queen
so you have to go back King to d8 and
now it's Queen g5 check came to c7 Queen
to f4 check King back to d8 and now
Knight to d6 and you are winning back
some material you're attacking the Queen
also threatening Knight of 6 7 check
that pick up the rook and here after all
is said and done captures King c8 and
this white would just be up material up
3 up 4 points of course in a completely
winning position so that's what happens
if King to d8 so Maxime of course played
teams to f8 and now what do you do here
your rook is under attack your knight is
under attack what can you do so here our
cengo finds the excellent rook to h6
threatening just rook captures which
would win the Queen so the rook has to
be captured rook characters on h6 Bishop
captures and h6 now threatening nasty
discoveries but here max and Maxime says
I'm done with all the all the nasty
discoveries you can throw at me so just
to rook captures and c2 and now the
problem is you don't have a good
discovery as ugly as that seems even a
double check or for example knight c6
check a check from knight and the bishop
doesn't yield any any results King
it and there's nothing to do you can
just repeat but now it's actually better
for black because black can simply hide
here and it black will have a much
better game so after rook captures on c2
we have Knights the f5 with check
alexandra says it's much more important
to get rid of the dark square Bishop
King to e8 and the now Knight captures
on e7 we have King captures on e7 and
now comes Queen to h4 with check and
again what do you do here maxime fairly
quickly played f6 because Knight to f6
again runs into a whole lot of
complications here there are there are a
lot of Muji you can try something like
Bishop to g7 but the critical move to
inspect is the rook captures and d6 and
now again
what do you play a problem is if you
capture with the King that's not good
because if you capture with the king
then Queen captures on f6 with check and
now not much you can do if you run away
Bishop the f4 gets the job done
and if you block with the Queen you no
longer guard the rook here so Bishop f4
check King d7 and now you can just go
Queen d4 check King to e8 King captures
and c2 and you are again in a better
position similar material but white is
up to fonts and well white will
definitely win this game
so when you have what you would have to
do after work address and e6 you'd have
to go night-night to d7 now to defend
here but now White has a route captures
here again because if you capture with
the Queen then white captures the rook
here you would have to play King
captures and now again Queen captures
here now you can go rook captures any -
but now it's Queen captures on f7 check
King to c6 and now again a draw by
repetition Queen f6 check and you of
course go back to the lights were here
you're gonna go Queen f7 check here and
so on of course you don't want to touch
the darks course and allow something
like a bishop therefore so again Queen
f6 checking the 7 Queen f7 and so on
sorry that that's a c7 accidentally I
put the King on c7 but King d7 and then
and then the the same idea applies so
after this Queen to h4 I check f6 was
played by Maxine and now comes Bishop to
f4 and again now it's a Maxime to move
what do you play so here really really
crazy position
can you can you pick up the bishop here
it does look like like like the piece
but the problem is Bishop captures and
these six runs into runs into a fourth
line Bishop captures an d6 check King to
e8 and now after check you're gonna move
Queen King to f7 Queen h7 here and this
is now Queen to e7 is checkmate
so not possible to capture it now the
question is what do you do here well
there are two lines extremely
complicated even pause the video and try
to find a continuation for Maxime here
while I give you a couple of seconds the
it's not like a find I find a good move
just try try to find something it's a
completely crazy position so for those
of you that even attempted to try
something in this position I I
congratulate you and you know I'm having
the will to do it and for those of you
just wanna enjoy the show there are a
couple of very interesting ideas here
there's of course Knight to d5 which is
just it just looks weird but it works
you're pressuring the bishop on f4 on
the other hand you're asking what do you
want to do here if if the knight is
captured then the point is you no longer
have access to the b6 pawn and then well
just row captures here it will be very
dangerous so here what you have to go
into is Queen to h7 check King to d8 and
now Queen the g8 with check King to c7
Queen captures and c8 King captures and
now King captures here and now after all
is said and done finally Knight captures
on f4 attacking the bishop bishop to f1
and we go into this end game where
Maxine would have two nights for a rook
but he would be down upon it sounds like
sounds like a great trade off but the
problem is these two points are kind of
weak the bishop it will be very hard for
the bishop to enter the game and also
there's the matter of the past H pawn
which could be could prove to be a bit
dangerous so Maxime decides that this is
a bit too dangerous to go for instead
Maxine goes for rook captures and b2
with check we have King capture sunbi to
Knight to a4 with check and now of
course you cannot allow Quintus III or
Queen to see to to come with check so a2
and a1 are off-limits you have to go to
b1 and now Knight to c3 with check King
to e1 and now you have to pick up the
rook as you want to get rid of this
threat so Knight captures and e1 and now
again if you play Bishop captures and b1
then you allow Queen c3 check and then
we again run into a perpetual Quincy for
check King to be to queen d4 check and
so on King to see to defend the bishop
now brush up the c6
Oh defending defending the knight here
so if the Queen starts checking you can
hide the King and the bishop will be
nicely defending the knight and if
anything even black can look for for
advantage here if white somehow that
doesn't go for a perpetual and tries to
keep the game alive so it would actually
be black who's better
so after Knight captures on d1 Alex & Co
instead went for a queen to h7 check
with King to d8 and now Queen to g8 with
check and here Maxime doesn't want to go
King c7 to allow a queen trade here
probably after characters characters and
Bishop characters and e1 it will be
somewhat somewhat better for white but
it's again again hard to say because you
do have the past H point and it's the
bishop pair against a knight and Bishop
on an open board would play on both
sides of the board so white should
definitely be better of course
Maxime is not interested in that so
after Queen g8 check Maxime go squinty
King to e7 to keep an eye on his pawns
here and only now Queen to h7 with check
and now it's not so interesting as the
King is already in the center of the
board so pink
Queen to h7 check King to d8 and now we
have a repetition King J checking g7 in
quint h7 check and it was in this
position unmoved 33 that Alexei
maximovich Telegraph agreed to a draw as
there doesn't seem to be a way to make
any more progress yes you could go for a
queen trade and then try to prove prove
you're better here but Alex and ko
it doesn't feel like like he will be
able to do it and of course both Maxime
and the engine agree with him so that's
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and also I always forgot forget to say
if you want to check out more photos
from the Fila can this turn
I will put a second link in the
description below it will be a link to
the official feed a Flickr site where
you can check out photos by official
photographers of the feed candidates
tournament Leonard told to Santa Maria I
mean Emilia Nova a lot of excellent
photos so do check it out if you're
interested in that and also if you still
haven't do check out the first link in
the description below wonderful video
bye bye bye a subscriber so once again I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Allah Shekhar amaz of Farrell
gainer peter haslund xin tian lei lien
and reporter for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usually contract to my
previous video series thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates a lot more excellent stuff
happened in around 5 so stay tuned I
think y'all I will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your Sunday